lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
algo fuera de lo común
he intentado este problema antes de
empezar a grabar el vídeo y de varias
formas lo he intentado y siempre obtuve
una respuesta distintas de una respuesta
distinta a las que están aquí así que
suponiendo que los que hicieron el
examen lo hicieron bien y es que este
examen es muy serio y es para para
ingresar a muchas universidades de
prestigio así que vamos a suponer que no
cometieron errores y me gustaría que
alguno de ustedes que está viendo este
vídeo me dijera dónde estoy cometiendo
un error y el problema dice así dice
sean pq números reales tales que no es 0
p elevado al cubo es distinto de q y p
elevado al cubo es distinto de menos q
ahora si alfa y beta son números
complejos distintos de 0 que cumplen que
su suma es decir alfa + beta es menos p
y alfa al cubo
más beta al cubo es decir la suma de sus
cubos es q entonces una ecuación
cuadrática que tienen como raíces a alva
/ beta
beta / alfa es y nos dan estas cuatro
opciones entonces yo no he podido
encontrar la respuesta correcta entonces
vamos a tratar de hacerlo en el vídeo y
ustedes me dirán dónde estoy cometiendo
el error muy bien entonces vamos a ver
esto si yo quiero un polinomio o una una
ecuación cuadrática y si escuadra tica
es decir es un polinomio de grado 2 y
debe tener como raíces a estos dos
entonces podemos ir explorando qué pasa
con x - alfa / beta verdad por x menos
beta / alfa este es una ecuación
cuadráticas y luego lo igualamos a 0
verdad y además estos dos son nuestras
raíces así que ahora vamos a ir
desarrollando tenemos x cuadrada
si x por x luego x por menos beta entre
alf es 3 menos beta entre alfa x luego -
alfa entre beta x - alfa entre beta x y
luego - alfa entre beta por - beta entre
alfa y realmente los signos se cancelan
se hacen más y alfa / alfa se cancela
beta / beta se cancela y nos queda 1
igual a 0 muy bien entonces lo que
podemos hacer ahorita es multiplicar de
ambos lados por alfa beta es decir
multiplicamos este lado por alfa beta y
también multiplicamos del lado derecho
ahora del lado derecho realmente pues
multiplicar 0 por lo que ustedes quieran
sigue siendo 0 verdad entonces esto será
igual a 0 y el detalle es que al
multiplicar por alfa beta de este lado
que es lo que nos queda si distribuimos
nos queda alfa beta por equis cuadrada
muy bien y luego alfa beta por menos
beta entre alfa las alfa se cancelan y
me queda beta cuadrada y con el signo
menos
- ve está cuadrada por equis y ahora
alfa beta por menos alfa / beta las
betas se cancelan y me queda menos
alfa por alfa que es alfa cuadrada x muy
bien y luego alfa beta por 1 pues
simplemente es alfa beta y déjenme
déjenme poner reacomodar esto donde
debería ir muy bien entonces aquí me
falta escribir más alfa beta y esto debe
ser 0 muy bien entonces si nos damos
cuenta aquí ya está todo en términos de
alfa si de betas pero en realidad
nuestras opciones que nos dan aquí sólo
están en términos de p y q entonces este
problema lo tenemos lo tenemos que
convertir a en términos de pq nada más
voy a simplificar un poco esto porque
puedo agrupar esto tengo alfa beta x
cuadrada esto lo dejamos igual y luego
voy a restar
alfa cuadrada + beta cuadrada que
multiplica x y aquí estamos agrupando
este término y este otro verdad factor
izamos un menos factor izamos la equis y
luego nos queda alfa cuadrada más beta
cuadrada y ahora sumó alfa beta igual a
cero entonces esta expresión de aquí
insisto ya está en términos de alfa y
beta ahora hay que tratar de
convertirlos a pq para ver cuál de estas
opciones es la que nos da entonces qué
es lo que podemos usar podemos usar que
alfa más beta es - p entonces fíjense si
tengo menos p igual a alfa más beta esto
esto es esta hipótesis verdad nos dicen
que alfa + beta es menos p entonces
queremos llegar digamos como alfa al
cubo más beta al cubo vamos a ver si
podemos lograrlo entonces qué pasa si
elevamos al cuadrado de ambos lados y
nos queda menos p
al cuadrado y esto simplemente es p
cuadrada verdad - p por menos p - por
menos es más
p por p esp cuadrado entonces ahí
quedamos y luego elevamos alfa más beta
al cuadrado eso es alfa cuadrada más 2
alfa beta más beta cuadrada verdad es
simplemente la fórmula de un binomio al
cuadrado y ahora porque estoy elevando a
las potencias pues justamente quiero
encontrar alfa al cubo y beta al cubo
suma 2 entonces quizás sí elevó yo p al
cubo puede encontrarlo vamos a ver si
tenemos
vamos a ver si tenemos menos pe al cubo
esto simplemente será menos p al cubo
verdad porque menos 1 al cubo es menos 1
x menos 1 x menos uno que es menos uno y
luego p al cubo éste al cubo y ya y
ahora pues no sé podríamos hacerlo de
distintas formas por ejemplo podríamos
multiplicar esto por alfa + beta o
simplemente elevar alfa más beta al cubo
y eso resolverlo con el triángulo de
pascal vamos a hacerlo de esa forma se
acaban del triángulo de pascal es 1
pongo 1 y 1 1 2 y 1 y aquí voy en el
piso 2 y aquí vamos al piso 3 13 31
entonces estos son los coeficientes de
cuando elevamos un binomio al cubo
verdad si si tienes duda de cómo estamos
utilizando el triángulo de pascal te
recomiendo que vayas a los vídeos de
sobre todo el teorema del binomio muy
bien entonces este menos p al cubo va a
ser alfa más beta al cubo y esto es alfa
al cubo
y va el 13 que es el siguiente
coeficiente alfa cuadrada beta + 3 alfa
beta cuadrada + beta al cubo entonces lo
único que puse fueron los coeficientes
de este nivel del triángulo de pascal y
después puse potencias de alfa y beta
las potencias de alfa van disminuyendo
hasta desaparecer y las de beta van
aumentando muy bien entonces lo que
podemos notar aquí es que tengo ahora si
mi alfa al cubo y me beta al cubo muy
bien entonces esto lo puedo poner como
menos p al cubo es menos b al cubo y
sabemos que alfa al cubo más beta al
cubo por hipótesis es q entonces aquí
podemos poner déjenme ponerlo así al
funk hubo más beta al cubo primero y
luego terminamos sumando el resto
3 alfa cuadrada beta + 3 alfa beta
cuadrada y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
ir simplificando fíjense muy bien
tenemos ya esto y entonces me queda
menos p al cubo ya empezamos de aquí
debe ser igual a alfa el cubo más beta
al cubo pero alfa el cubo más beta al
cubo es q verdad entonces aquí tengo
aquí tengo aquí y luego factor hizo de
esto verde que me queda por factorizar
tres veces alfa beta
tengo tres veces alfa beta que
multiplica a alfa más beta verdad
simplemente fue factor izando 3 alfa
beta pero alfa más beta alfa más beta es
menos p es menos p y eso está aquí
verdad entonces vamos a reescribir lo
esto simplemente es menos p
p al cubo igual a q mas 3 alfa beta por
menos p muy bien y entonces nosotros
podemos despejar alfa beta y que nos
sirve mucho justamente porque aquí
tenemos alfa civetas de hecho alfa beta
verdad entonces vamos a tratar de
despejarlo
por ejemplo pasamos restando q y nos
queda menos p al cubo menos q igual a
igual a menos 3 alfa beta por p verdad
simplemente pasando el signo menos hasta
acá y ahora dividimos todo entre menos 3
p dividimos todo entre menos 3 p y nos
quedan menos p al cubo menos q sobre
menos 3 p esto es igual a alfa beta muy
bien y este menos lo que puede hacer es
simplemente tengo aquí menos esto entre
menos esto pues los menos se cancelan y
simplemente escribir p al cubo
sobre 3 p esto es igual a alfa por beta
muy bien y esto esta expresión nos cae
muy bien y justamente por lo siguiente
notemos notemos que hay quien sería alfa
cuadrada más b está cuadrada aquí aquí
tenemos un alfa cuadrada más b está
cuadrada tenemos que determinar quién es
eso verdad pero también tenemos aquí
esta parte este alfa
si no tenemos aquí alfa cuadrada más b
está cuadrada es p cuadrada muy bien
entonces y además tenemos aquí dos alfa
beta y ya sabemos quién es alfa beta
entonces podemos calcularlo muy bien
alfa cuadrada más b está cuadrada verdad
si lo tomamos de esta ecuación es p
cuadrada menos dos alfa beta y eso sale
de aquí arriba muy bien pero alfa beta
ya sabemos quién es entonces esto será p
cuadrada menos dos veces alfa beta que
es p outs gp
al cubo más q sobre 3 p muy bien
entonces tenemos esto y vamos a sacar un
común divisor entonces si dividimos
bueno si queremos expresar t cuadrada
con denominador 3 p esto será 3 p al
cubo entre 3 p verdad los tres se
cancelan y p al cubo entre p esp
cuadrada menos 2 p al cubo déjenme
ponerlo así incluso
- 2 p al cubo vamos a distribuir lo
menos 2 q entre 3 p y si nosotros
sumamos esto que nos queda tenemos 3 p
al cubo menos 2 p al cubo así que me
queda solo uno solo me queda 1 verdad
entonces esto será igual a p al cubo
menos 2 q entre 3 p porque tenemos el
mismo el mismo denominador entonces ya
podemos ir
simplificando todo esto de la siguiente
forma porque fíjense tengo alfa beta
entonces este alfa beta este alfa beta
lo puedo sustituir por esta expresión de
aquí entonces tengo p al cubo más q
entre 3 p que multiplica nuestra x
cuadrada
- - esta expresión de aquí entonces de
hecho esta expresión de aquí es
justamente esta de aquí muy bien tenemos
esta de aquí entonces menos p al cubo
menos 2 q entre 3 p que multiplica a x
muy bien más alfa beta nuevamente
tenemos alfa beta por segunda ocasión
aquí entonces más p al cubo más q entre
3 p y esto debe ser igual a 0 verdad
entonces seguimos teniendo la misma
ecuación cuadrática pero alfa y beta
después de resolver muchas operaciones
ya lo dejamos en términos de pq muy bien
entonces en realidad si nos fijamos en
nuestras respuestas en nuestras posibles
respuestas aquí nunca están dividiendo
entre 3 p y la ventaja que tenemos en
ese sentido es que estamos igualando a
cero así que si por ejemplo
multiplicamos de ambos lados por 3
qué es lo que nos quedaría pues se
cancela se cancelan los tres que quedan
abajo en el denominador de cada término
entonces nos queda p al cubo más q que
multiplica a equis cuadrada menos
p al cubo menos 2 q que multiplica x más
p al cubo más q verdad que bueno esto lo
podemos agrupar en derecho y esto es
igual a cero entonces déjenme copiar
déjenme seleccionar esto para ver si
coincide con alguna de nuestras
respuestas
vamos a copiarlo
y ver si coincide
aquí lo tenemos
y estamos muy contentos porque ahora sí
no sé cómo le dice ahora que sí me salió
y de hecho la respuesta es la ve verdad
así que ahí está la respuesta esto es
esta es la respuesta correcta estoy
bastante emocionado me retracto de lo
que les había dicho al inicio realmente
creo que no necesite su ayuda al final
bueno quizás si necesita su ayuda verdad
en el proceso de enseñanza esa era la
ayuda que necesitaba pero bueno de
cualquier forma espero que este
ejercicio te haya resultado útil